[Music]
so you're one of the great comic
Impressionists in the world right now
and you've channeled some of my dream
guests in the past so what I'm hoping as
I can just you know if you'll humor me
hit you with some and then maybe you
review our hot sauce does that sound
good
great DMX when you think of the hot
sauce um you know listen Dawg you the
only [ __ ] thing is this you know you
know it doesn't really baby but you know
I'm just trying to be I'm just trying to
clear my vocal cords because it's a lot
of mucus build up on the cord bird hi
it's delicious [ __ ]
I love these wings Steven Naismith what
do you think listen this wing is very
delicious and you know what reminds me
it's excited not like Tim Duncan who is
not excited who plays the most
fundamental game but he gets the job
done and that's all that's important
these wings can basically have you just
watering at the mouth like you're
looking at a beverage with with a heavy
ass I don't know when I have your
own--you
Eddie Murphy what do you think of the
wing and what do you think this is a
minute sauce is amazing man you notice
I'm trying to figure out why me hotter
than it is or you know I'm saying to
juice is it's normal to me you know I
like spicy stuff you don't say you know
spice I'm gonna I put Indian cloves I
know spiciness Eddie that's what some
people say you know they're like they
expect our hot sauce to be like the
hottest hot sauce but we wanted a good
tasting smooth hot sauce but I think
that's a fair it's a very smooth is very
cool smooth hot sauce now if you ask any
shop the same question you would have a
son Shannon said it ain't like you ever
been with a Mexican
we got a duster on Shannon you know
sometime they will take a habanero and
they put him inside of your margarita
and then you wake up and then all your
money's gone
but you're both empty kind of a net
buzzer I think you're in the green on
that one what about our Will Smith what
do you think ah you know what like yo
like this is crazy you know I mean like
it's a good sauce you know I like it um
you know Jayden wouldn't like this he
was saying no because
I'm saying is you know it's you know
yeah it just takes birth ain't off the
ball with Daddy you know but over there
Zoe I'm Dan tenza this wing is very
delicious huh
it reminds me you know if it gets any
hotter then a tear is gonna come down my
face just like it did in glory because
I'm going through it huh I love it whoa
huh
stand up now huh that's what you need to
tell everybody who tries to take the
milk man don't [ __ ] up but I love this J
and I'm gonna remember these moments J
Chia I'll go JC jaywalking a badge a
talking this one I love you Lisa you
know haven't felt this good since you
know the first time it me and Beyonce
fornicate
we just do some water right let's do
this it's a hundred percent pansy city's
it hurts us why would you put this on
the brain you idiots
this can make my bowel movements
terrible you keep upping the ante okay
Sam that was hard this out of the game
changes hold a little you know